[موسيقى]
أنا في مستشفى ألاكا في المنطقة الوسطى
من قطاع غزة، الجزء الأوسط من قطاع غزة، في
قسم الطوارئ حيث
يعالجون
الأطفال العديد من الأطفال على الأرض
وعلى خلفية رمادية، الأطباء
ينادون بالمشرط والصدر  حساء أم أن العديد من
الأشخاص قادمون من انفجار
هناك طفل توفي لسوء الحظ
ولم يتم التعرف على جثته وهو
كما ترون مشهد فوضوي أه
لسوء الحظ هذه المنطقة أه
قريبة من المنطقة التي تم أه إخلاؤها
بالأمس صدر أمر إخلاء  صدر
وأم لقد فقدوا الكثير من موظفيهم،
ويعمل هذا المستشفى حاليًا
بحوالي 30٪ من الموظفين الذين كان لديهم
قبل بضعة أيام فقط، وهم يرون
في بعض الحالات مئات الضحايا
كل يوم في قسم طوارئ صغير
أه  قالوا بالأمس أن
لديهم طبيبًا واحدًا يعمل طوال الليل في
قسم الطوارئ هذا مع وصول المئات في
بعض الحالات من الإصابات
يوميًا،
هناك مرضى يأتون كل بضع
دقائق، إنه
مشهد فوضوي حقًا تحدث إلينا مدير المستشفى للتو
و  وقال إن طلبه الوحيد
هو حماية هذا المستشفى على الرغم
من مغادرة العديد من موظفيه على الرغم من أن
هذا المستشفى يتعرض
لضغوط هائلة. والطلب الوحيد الذي
قاله مدير المستشفى هو أن
المجتمع الدولي بحاجة
للتأكد من أن هذا المستشفى والمستشفيات الأخرى
مثل ذلك، ابقوا محميين، حتى
لا يتعرضوا للضرب، حتى لا يتم إجلاؤهم،
لكي يكونوا قادرين على مواصلة
العمل، هذه هي الرسالة المهمة
لهذا
اليوم